our short National sorial nightmare is
over as the US Senate officially and
unanimously votes to make John fedman
get dressed before coming to work at the
supposedly greatest deliberative body in
the world a bipartisan resolution titled
the show our respect to the Senate act
the shorts act s h it was somewhat
labored but they call it the shorts act
it was put forward by Democrat Joe
mansion and sort of Republican Mitt
Romney requiring that male Senators wear
a quotequote tie and slacks or other
long pants on the senate floor or else
risk removal by the Sergeant at Arms the
shorts Act is the most productive
legislative work that the US Senate has
done this term the Senators can't figure
out how to fix the Border crisis or
revive the economy or even fund the
government but they have finally now at
least figured out how to dress
themselves which is a good start I'm
Michael nolles this is the Michael nlls
[Music]
show welcome back to the show with have
a blazing headline today that AI sex
chatbots are ruining a generation of men
we'll get to why and how that is in a
second first though speaking of the
Senate we have some breaking news right
now which is that Senator Diane
Feinstein has died Diane Feinstein was
up there in years people have called on
her to retire in recent years I have not
Diane Feinstein was a big Democrat
certainly I've always kind of liked her
I I have said for months now I did not
want her to retire at all I actually was
endorsing her for about three more terms
because she's much better than anything
else we were going to get out of
California uh she she had a many decades
long political career there were some uh
Infamous moments along the way that
conservatives had a lot of fun with like
when uh Senator
Feinstein grilled Amy Coney Barrett over
whether or not the Dogma lived loudly
within her and so there were these
moments as there are for every
politician where people would always
just focus on them but broadly
speaking they come a lot worse than
Diane Feinstein as far as Democrat
Senators go Diane Feinstein was was
really one of my favorites and I love
that she stuck it out until the end and
refused to retire or resign even as many
members of her own party were trying to
force her to and so certainly pray for
the Repose of her soul and uh and pray
for whoever comes next in California who
almost certainly will be much much worse
than Diane Feinstein the the politically
significant aspect of her death is this
look D she lived a good long life you
know it's it's not as though she was cut
down in her prime in her 20s she lived a
good long life a a very uh respectable
career as a US senator uh but what it
means for us is that we have a
gerontocracy I'm not even saying that's
a terrible thing but our country is run
by very aged people people who are older
even than usual in the Senate you know
the word Senate comes from from senx
which means old man but even still by
historical standards we have an aged
group of people running the country and
that means that at any moment they could
die not wishing ill on any of these
people but Mitch McConnell is up there
in years Schumer's up there in years Joe
Biden obviously up there in yours even
Donald Trump he seems a lot more
vigorous than the rest of them but he's
no spring chicken and
so the advantage of having older people
running the show is that they do have
more WI wisdom we Hope they've certainly
had more experience I'm not one of these
people who's totally opposed to old guys
running things but it does open you up
to the potential of real chaos if
someone happens to die it it is
entirely possible that the incumbent
president as he seeks re-election might
not make it for health reasons and in
that case what what will happen this is
something I've said as the flip side of
our gerontocracy for a long time which
is the longer this goes on the longer
that the Boomers and the silent
generation hold on to power the more
radical the transformation will be when
the younger generation takes over
because the younger generation as always
views things a little bit differently
than the older generation do and and we
have had a period of relative stability
in the way that we view our own
political order and in our rhetoric
because it's been the same people
running the show for 50 years but that
is that is an illusion that is going to
go away the moment that these people go
away uh so the Senate will continue on
at least now theyve figured out how to
dress themselves uh and John Federman
will have to put on a suit for work
speaking of men at work I didn't get to
it yesterday but I do want to touch on
this while the undercard was debating at
the Reagan Library for the Republican
primary nomination battle uh Donald
Trump went to Michigan to Rally with
striking Auto Workers here was his
message crooked Joe and his payday
with the Biden family they raked in
millions and millions of dollars you see
what's going on the news doesn't really
reported very little news reports it but
it was the men and women who got every
single day they got up and came back
home with grease on their hands and they
were the ones that paid the price they
paid a big big price the only time Joe
Biden has ever gotten his hands dirty is
when he's taking cash from foreign
countries which is quite often actually
it's quite often it's a good line it's
the only time Joe's ever gotten his
hands dirty okay what do we take away
from this speech the speech went well it
was a good as far as rallies go was good
uh I don't think it made a ton of
news I don't know that it distracted too
much attention from the GOP undercard
debate but I don't know that that many
people watched the GOP undercard debate
and I don't think that that debate
really moved the needle for anyone
people performed basically as expected
some people underperformed I felt Nikki
hurt herself I felt Tim Scott kind of
hurt himself uh DeSantis did well as
expected V did basically as well as
expected so I don't think it really
moved the needle so what do we conclude
from the Trump event we conclude that he
is running in the general election
already this rally was focused on Joe
Biden crooked Joe the only time he's
ever gotten his hands dirty is when he's
taking money so he he is focused he is
behaving as though the primary were
already over and the primary is not
already over but every indication would
suggest that Donald Trump is going to be
the nominee the national polls the state
polls the number of committed delegates
in for instance the Iowa caucuses the
the relative lack of change for the
polls over time so it's probably smart
for Trump to focus on the general
election but he's still going to have
this he's still going to have this
primary and as as we have seen today uh
anything anything can happen uh speaking
of presidential candidates though and
one of those crazy things that could
happen Gavin
Nome as he prepares for his debate with
Ronda Sanz the undercard of the
potential presidential nominees Gavin
Nome was asked a question
[Music]
about look he doesn't back away from the
question he doesn't seem to be on his
heels oh well no look what I really mean
actually look come on guys he says it's
1% of the population this is rid
ridiculous these kids want to live they
want to live and climate change is going
to kill us all oh come on you kidding
me H do you ever listen to Huey Lewis in
the news try getting a reservation at
Doria now president
Trump people underestimate Nome at their
own Peril this guy I'm not saying he's
going to be the Democrat nominee because
I think Joe Biden is going to hold on as
long as he can
but sometimes Desiring to hold on is not
good enough I mean Joe is not in charge
of his faculties and as we see anything
can happen if Governor Nome and I fled
him I fled nini's failed hell State of
California okay I I've seen this guy's
policies very
close if this guy is the Democrat
nominee I don't care if you've got
Donald Trump who I think is a singular
political talent I know some people
think he's less talented I think he's
pretty impressive but if it's Donald
Trump going up against Nome if it's
Ronda santis going up against Nome Ronda
santis has a billion times better record
as governor of Florida the Newsome has
is governor of California I don't care
if it's any of those guys I don't care
if it's V I don't care who the
Republican nominee is that guy will be
tough to beat that guy will be a lot
tougher to beat than people are
suggesting he's just pure Riz okay the
guy has got Riz and we got to talk about
that when you want to talk to your
friends you got to talk about pure talk
right now head on over to Pur talk.com
you know a company is looking out for
you when they actually upgrade your
service and don't charge you for it this
is great news for new and current peer
talk customers peer talk just added data
to every plan and includes a mobile
hotspot with no price increase
whatsoever if you've considered pure
talk before but have not made the switch
take a look again for just $20 a month
you will get unlimited talk text and now
50% 50% more 5G data Plus plus their new
mobile hotspot this is why I love Pure
Talk they're veteran-owned they only
hire the best customer service team
located right here in the USA most
families are saving almost $1,000 a year
while enjoying the most Dependable 5G
Network in America remember when you
vote you can vote with your ballot and
you can vote with your money so stop
supporting woke wireless companies that
don't support you when you go to Pur
talk.com you will save an additional
5050 z% off your first month because
they value you that is peer talk.com
peer Talk Wireless for Americans by
Americans Governor Nome man for all his
many sins he is teeming with Riz and
speaking of Riz from Democrat
politicians do you guys know maybe some
of you are not familiar with Jen Z lingo
I'm a hip hop and cool cat so I know how
the kids talk these days really it's
short for Charisma okay that's what we
say when we're hanging out at you know
the sock hop smoking sigs behind the gym
uh Anthony blinket
the Secretary of State for Joe Biden
just showed off some of his RZ when he
played a set of hoochi coochi man on a
left-handed Fender Stratocaster at the
global music diplomacy
initiative woman told my
mother before I was
born going to be a man child
coming going to be son of a
gun going to make
women's J
shout and the world will
know what it's all about you know I'm
here everybody knows I'm
[Music]
here coochie coochie
man everybody knows I
[Music]
I want to hate
it I want to hate it I'm waiting when I
saw this thumbnail load up I thought oh
man here comes the cringe gge your loins
hold on for deer comes the cringe and
then he started playing and he's
surprisingly good it's not Jeff Beck you
know it's not he's not Jimmy Hendry he's
not Muddy
Waters but his rhythm playing was
basically fine it's kind of he's playing
a left-handed Strat his pitch and tone
as a singer surprisingly good it's hard
for white guys to sing uh songs that
have basically only ever been performed
by black guys or only ever been
persuasively performed by black guys and
he he did it pretty well I thought I I
was actually pretty impressed this is
today is my day of saying nice things
about Democrats I'm saying that Diane
Feinstein was not the worst US senator
by a long shot I'm saying that uh
Governor baitman over there in
California might be a stone cold
psychopath who feeds stray cats to ATMs
but he's a political talent and I'm
going to say Anthony blinkin Secretary
of
State a pretty good little guitarist you
know he's got a decent pitch on him too
and I I really like that I like it when
politicians when political leaders have
hobbies when they have other interests
when they don't then then I just assume
they are pure psychopathy that they are
just absolute 100% grade A sociopathy
whereas if like Churchill if they paint
you know if like blink and if they play
guitar and sing Muddy Waters I don't if
if they have other interests it makes me
think that they are at least somewhat
human and they are not merely focused on
the acquisition of power for no other
purpose than wielding it now speaking of
hobbies turning from good edifying
hobbies to dubious Hobbies there's a
story out in the hill
says AI girlfriends are ruining an
entire generation of men it's by Liberty
viit and I didn't even know what this
meant you know I'm hip and I'm young and
I'm cool and I talk to the kids and I
got Riz and I smoke sigs behind the gym
and I'm you know go to the sock hop and
everything but I didn't even know what
this meant and what what I learned from
this column is that there are apps there
are apps that uh simulate
girlfriends and they've got a lot of
users like a shocking number of users in
fact there's one gal who she's an
influencer she's a real human being she
made an AI bot of herself named Karen
and got 1,000 paying users in less than
a week and a weight list of more than
15,000 people so it's generating
millions and millions of dollars and a
lot of PE many more people want to use
it than even are able to use it right
now and it's not just like they're
logging in and you know it's just some
rote computer program the AI learns what
your desires are and then tailors its
messages to your desires mostly sexual
one would assume but maybe some of your
other inclinations and interests as well
the AI learns from all this to assuage
the silent epidemic of loneliness that
is hitting this generation of young men
according to vit more than 60% of young
men ages 18 to 30 are single compared to
only 30% of women of the same age so
you've got now the clear majority of men
18 to 30 are single that's brutal one in
five men report not having a single
close friend and that number has
quadrupled in the last 30 years and I
know it man I see
it this is so much more than just about
sex this is about people not having
friends people not being able to go out
and have a drink with somebody or a
cigar with somebody or I guess that's
most what I do with my friends but go
out and you know play a game of pool or
just chat
or it's it's increasingly rare to have
friends these days and people who don't
have friends I mean loneliness is such a
painful experience they think that
they're the only ones obviously if
you're lonely you feel lonely you feel
isolated but this is a widespread social
problem huge number of people who have
no close
relationships especially with a a girl
the amount of social engagement with
friends has dropped by 20 hours per
month over the coid lockdowns so you say
five hours per
week it's still decreasing and so this
professor Liberty VD says that America
desperately needs people to have more
babies but all signs are pointing toward
fewer relationships fewer marriages and
fewer babies and people are going to
mock this to me the saddest part is is
the crisis faced by so many people of
not having any close friends which is
not just a personal problem maybe it's
that you know you're you've got to work
on your personality and your virtue and
all those things a little bit but you
can't say it's just a personal problem
if it's widespread throughout the whole
society then it's a political problem
and we need some cultural and political
uh campaign to fix it because the issue
was caused by cultural and political
factors as well that's why it affects so
many people and this is especially true
when it comes
to romances that could lead to marriage
that could lead to babies none of which
we're getting right now people are going
to mock this and they're going to say
you freak you weirdo pervert you'd
rather have a relationship with a
chatbot sitting in your mother's
basement all by
yourself getting getting weird sexual
messages from a computer than go out
there and have a girlfriend what a
weirdo what a freak you
are but I I see why this is
tempting in fact the professor says it
too he says this is a way to assuage the
loneliness epidemic so so you're feeling
lonely then you start using weirdo tools
like this and then it it seems like a
little Band-Aid on the problem of
loneliness because you're getting the
simulacrum of a relationship but you
know it's not real so then you become
even more lonely even more isolated even
more encouraged in your weird sexual
desires and and the problem only
compounds on itself it
snowballs and I see why it's tempting
too if you if you have a real girlfriend
she can tell you no if you have a real
girlfriend she's a human being who you
have to respect it's not just about the
satisfaction of your own desires as
weird as they
come I I I get why men in Japan notably
but even in the United States would turn
to porn rather than have a girlfriend I
get why they would turn to these weird
sex robots instead of having a
girlfriend in a way one could more
directly satisfy their apparent desires
and selfish longings with one of these
things that isn't actually human that
doesn't really have a soul or
Consciousness over a human
being totally and so if you're an
atheist if you're a materialist if you
think that this world is just kind of
stuff and that our our Consciousness or
our sense of longing and Love and Desire
and dreams that's all just an illusion
caused by misfiring little electrical
impulses in our
brains then there is no argument against
this there is no materialist secular
argument against the weirdo porn AI chat
robots there isn't
one and there are many uh Arguments for
using them in a culture that's extremely
lonely at a time when the highest and
only moral maximum is if it feels good
do it and the more people indulge those
impulses as they are the worse the
society and the individuals are going to
get but in a world without
God there's no argument against it
there's no way to stop the
psychological social and civilizational
suicide doesn't look good when you want
to look good though you got to check out
Jus cell right now go to genucell.com as
you might know we are all fans of our
friends at Jus cell don't just take my
word for it Ella from Rockford says I
have both age and acne spots and this
stuff is actually fading both of them
this Serum is worth every penny Ella is
raving about the famous Dark Spot
Corrector from Jus cell a must have
after months of record heat and humidity
sunspots brown spots disc coloration
even red inflamed patches all disappear
in front of your very eyes and here's
the genus cell amazing guarantee you
will see results on day one or your
money back so take advantage of genus
cell's most popular package which now
includes the Dark Spot Corrector plus
the classic genus cell bags and
puffiness treatment and immediate
effects all for about 70 70% off so you
can try the best skincare in the world
for yourself absolutely risk-free it is
very simple you go to Jus cell.com kwes
start looking years even decades younger
tomorrow say goodbye to dark and liver
spots bags and puffiness under the eyes
and crowsfeet at genucell.com
that is Jus cell.com
I've told you time and time again and I
hate to say it it pains me but I have to
say it because I have to be honest with
you I told you so yes or no the game has
sold out over at dailywire.com shop
again it will come back into stock but
you need to secure your game today if
you have not already if you want to play
it at Halloween if you want to play it
at Thanksgiving if you want to play it
at Christmas order it now so that it
doesn't run out of stock and then you
miss out also if you've already got the
classic game be sure to get the allnew
conspiracy theory expansion pack just in
time for spooky season and speaking of
my collection and the rapidly
approaching change of season if you're
even mildly familiar with this show
you're aware of my Affinity for a
certain seasonal treat you know a little
autumnal beverage known as the pumpkin
spice latte so what better way to bring
the fall atmosphere into your home than
with the allnew Michael noll's pumpkin
spice
candle cinnamon vanilla pumpkin spice
wow delicious available right now in my
collection don't wait order your candles
and the yes or no game today your whole
your whole room can be filled with my
musk which this time of year is pure
100% unadulterated pumpkin spice go to
dailywire.com
shop today my favorite comment yesterday
is from Matthew Smith hyphen CP3 hu what
a strange name who says what I want to
see is how states are going to hold an
honest and fair election I I'm with you
I'm with you I you know I like a number
of the candidates who are running for
the presidential nomination I like Trump
I really like Trump as you know I like
Ronda santis I think he's a great
Governor I like f ramaswami he's a
friend of mine he's a very impressive
guy obviously I love Doug bergham the
future emperor of the the country once
once we move into full caesarism and the
bergam bergam momentum takes off then
he's going to run the whole country but
you know a number of the candidates I
really really like it it does seem
likely to me that Trump is going to be
the nominee and if you like the other
candidates more sorry you know and could
something change of course anything
could change maybe DeSantis pulls a
rabbit out of his hat and wins the
nomination maybe vake surges up and and
becomes a nomin I'm not saying it's not
possible just seems to me since the
polls essentially haven't changed in 14
months and it because Trump is
essentially running as an incumbent uh
it just seems to me very likely that
he'll be the nominee so I'm just not as
focused over the sniping of the
individual campaigns at each other and
every time you know there's a bad clip
of trump or a bad clip of disantis or a
bad clip of V or some Oppo comes up
somewhere I'm not even that interested
in reporting on the news of it because I
just don't think it's really
consequential I don't think any of it
really moves the needle what I am
focused on is no matter who the nominee
is can that person beat a Democrat and
part of that is going to be personality
and popularity and part of that is going
to be are the Democrats going to rig the
election do I'm fairly confident that
the election was fairly rigged in 2020
okay and I'm fairly confident of that
because the Democrats admitted it and
that they changed all the rules in some
cases in contravention of the State
Constitution as in the case of
Pennsylvania they did that was it
significant enough to flip the election
I don't know maybe maybe it was so if
Trump is the nominee again what's to
stop them from doing that again this is
the argument made by the disantis camp
and some of the other Camp campaigns and
it's a good argument but but then my
response to that argument is well what's
to stop them from stealing it from you
you know we're talking about a
structural political issue here that
Republicans need to get ser serious
about or else all of these debates not
just the one at the Reagan Library but
all of these debates in the primary are
abstract and theoretical and not going
to amount to much if the Democrats Rigg
the whole system to give them an
instrument Advantage okay speaking of
dubious
apps you guys remember
threads do you remember Facebook threads
that it's not as though I'm saying hey
you remember Myspace hey do you remember
live Journal hey do you remember AOL
Instant Messenger apps from years and
decades
ago Facebook rolled out threads which
was going to be its Twitter
alternative like two months ago or
something and now I hadn't even
remembered it until I was on my
Instagram account and I saw some link to
it said all right there's a threat it's
that thing that didn't that completely
flamed out CNBC is reporting
that upon the launch of Facebook threads
it looked like it posed a real chance of
of being a formidable competitor to
Twitter and then it just
collapsed the forecast predicts a US
user base of 23.7 million people for
Threads in
2023 that is significantly less than
half of the 56.1 million anticipated us
users of X formerly known as
Twitter and Twitter was always the
smallest of the big social media sites
so compared to Facebook Instagram and
Tik Tok it's relatively small because
Facebook has 177.1 million users
Instagram has
135.299 threads just
completely collapsed less than half of
Twitter not even registering in the
conversation my takea away from this is
it was in fact smart of Elon to buy
Twitter at the time he bought it for $44
billion people said this is a big waste
of money there's look maybe the company
will still go bankrupt to test financial
problems but if the point was for Elon
to have control over one of the big
Platforms in our Public Square to
actually get messages out there it was
smart to buy Twitter all the lib said if
Elon buys Twitter we're going to get off
Twitter we're going to stop using it
it's going to collapse we're all going
to go someplace else and they don't they
don't and they never do they never go to
social they never go to parlor they
never go to gab they never go to threads
they never it's no knock on any of those
platforms
but these platforms have a lot more
staying power and inertia than they have
previously been given credit for a lot
of people said well look you remember
Myspace and then Myspace went away so
some new company will do that's not how
it works anymore in those early days of
the internet and the New Media things
were a little more tempestuous than they
were they've really settled down though
and the institutions especially Google
especially Facebook and to a much lesser
degree Twitter they control the Public
Square this is why it was so dangerous
when the big Tech platforms censored the
hunter Biden laptop story including from
private
messages because in a
republic such as we are supposed to be
if you control speech you control the
whole political order because the way we
govern ourselves is supposedly by
persuading one another and deliberating
the Senate is called the greatest
deliberative body in the world we speak
to one another we make speeches we make
arguments and then we we persuade enough
people to get some things done if you
control speech in the Public Square you
control effectively the whole political
order and that's what these
unaccountable billionaires in Silicon
Valley had been doing all for the
left Twitter comes in well Elon comes
into Twitter and just shifts it and
makes it more amenable to conservatives
and it worked and it had staying power
conservatives in recent years have been
eager to flee the old institutions they
said the old institutions are so
hollowed out so desicated screw it let
the libs have them we're going to build
our own institutions it's good to start
building our own institutions obviously
that's what we're trying to do here at
the daily wire but that is not enough we
should not seed the institutions to the
left that's how we lost the universities
and the libs went in and hollowed out
those universities and made them zombies
of what they once were but they still
have some Prestige they still have some
influence if if we want to
get back to any state of normal in the
United States we've got to fight over
those we've got to have hostile
takeovers ret takeovers of those
institutions we need we need Elon Musk
and people like Elon Musk I guess there
aren't very many because he's the
richest man in the world to go in and
put their money where our mouths are and
take those institutions and kick out the
bad guys and turn them a little bit more
in the right direction and start
wielding them for our interests which
happen to be more in line with Justice
and virtue and a flourishing Society
don't give them up don't concede them
don't say well you're going to have them
it's all lost tactical Retreats can be
fine sometimes you got to tactically
retreat from Harvard to Hillsdale to get
your troops back up but but that's only
to mount another attack on Harvard and
go in and take it sometimes you need to
tactically retreat from California to
Texas or California to Tennessee but not
to say we don't care what happens in
California anymore only so that you can
get your forces strong enough again to
go back there and fight those battles in
California and throughout the United
States so that we have a flourishing
Society Sometimes the best defense is a
good offense speaking of building
institutions there's a report out from
60 Minutes the US has dumped $25 billion
into non-military foreign aid for
Ukraine so while we're now hearing that
that our military servicemen in the
United States will work and not be paid
in the event of a government shutdown
shop owners in Ukraine are still going
to keep getting checks from me and you
checks not not for arms not for guns not
for tanks just to keep the lights on
keep bacing bread keep selling products
keep the hotels open non-military Aid in
addition to the 43 billion in military
aid we've dumped nearly 25 billion into
non-military Aid and the right is gasped
over this and shocked and horrified I'm
not shocked at all this is what Empires
do we are an Empire the war in Ukraine
is an imperial war between the United
States and Russia Russia
two large Powers formerly both great
Powers now Russia's considerably
degraded but still two relatively great
Powers fighting over territory that the
East and the West have fought over for a
long time and what Empires do is not
merely Supply bullets and guns and
things but they wield their resources
and their power to keep the whole
country afloat that's what happens we
are inevitably going to throw our power
around and to pretend that we're not
going to do that anymore is to ignore
reality and to continue to see these
institutions to the left the question
that we should be asking is not should
we throw our weight around should we
have influence in the world should we be
the great powerful country that we are
the question is what are we going to use
that power for are we going to use it to
hoist Pride Flags in Kandahar or are we
going to use it to spread truth justice
in the American way to to expand the the
founding example of the United States to
be shining City on a Hill to be a model
of Christian charity what is we are
going
to impose or at least impel the adoption
of our values around the world we can
put our heads in the sand and pretend
that's not the case and let the left
just have fun doing it or we can get
into the nitty-gritty and say what
values are we going to share is it going
to be the American flag is it going to
be the Cross of Christ and Christendom
or is it going to be the rainbow flag
what what what's it going to be it's
going it's going to be something now
there's a story I'm just going to tease
this there's a story out there big
blaring headline on Drudge Report will
there be a late entrant into the GOP
Primary race and who you know who it was
going to be before you even click the
headline there's
scuttlebutt there's talk out of Virginia
that Glenn yunan could be a last minute
entry into the GOP
race to which I said
say well I'm out of time that'll be my
tease we'll have to talk more about it
on Monday you know when Dr Jordan
Peterson made the decision to join daily
plus it was a major win for those who
Champion intellectual debate with one
year of unparalleled output his
contributions have set new standards and
remained unmatched by any other platform
dailywire plus now has a vast array of
exclusive Jordan content offering
hundreds of hours of captivating content
you won't find anywhere else Jordan has
created thought-provoking works that
reshape your perspective on life which
include
vision and Destiny marriage and Dragons
monsters and men and and and there's so
many commas and ANS I don't even know
where one show begins and another one
ends Additionally you can immerse
yourself in discussions that nurture
your spiritual side like logos and
literacy Jordan's groundbreaking Series
in the book of Exodus that's only the
beginning I have not even mentioned his
Beyond order lecture series well I guess
now I just did mention it or his
extensive Archive of lectures and
podcasts I guess I mentioned those to
this is the absolute compendium of all
things Jordan there is even more new
exclusive content on the Horizon by
becoming a daily wi plus member you will
embark on an unforgettable experience
that will fuel your thirst for knowledge
and Inspire personal growth like never
before go to dailywire.com
subscribe to become a member
today finally finally I've arrived at my
favorite time of the week which is when
I get to hear from you in the mailbag
this mailbag is sponsored by P talk go
to Pur talk.com kwes to save an
additional 50% off your first
month Hey Dirty Mike Mr reality here I
had a question for you about Trump's
poll numbers specifically from that ABC
poll that you talked about on your show
on Monday the ABC polling has a history
of being wildly wrong specifically in
2016 a few weeks before the election
they had Hillary Clinton up double
digits over Trump and we know how that
turned out so my question for you is
given that the mainstream media clearly
wants Trump to be the nominee uh either
for their ratings or because they think
it'll be easier for Biden to beat and
given their history of Faking polls
which we all know is true my question is
do you think it could be an effort by
the mainstream media to help Trump get
elected to make fake polls showing that
he is electable Ben's talked about the
underlying numbers on some of these
polls that show him winning huge support
from black voters which is unheard of in
Republican circles for example uh do you
think the polls could be fake to take
out the disantis argument or do you
think they're real this time thanks and
if you do think they're real why thanks
certainly could be an example of the
media wanting Trump to be the nominee I
don't think the media consciously want
Trump to be the nominee I I don't think
it's that they're all in a room and
they're sitting there smoking you know
smoke filed room probably Vape smelled
room if it's the liberal media and
they're saying okay we're all going to
do guys is we're going to pretend that
we hate Trump but secretly we love Trump
because he gets us ratings so what we're
going to do is give him the nomination
okay you all got your marching orders
let's go out there and pretend to hate
Trump they they sincerely hate him they
really hate him more than they hate
other
Republicans but uh like someone in a
perverse romantic relationship they they
also love him because he does give them
ratings that that's true he's ratings
gold nobody comes close uh so if it were
merely that if it were merely media
coverage I would say okay maybe this is
uh being trumped up pun intended to get
the more ratings and if it were merely
the ABC Washington Post poll I would say
yeah maybe it's a cooked poll I'm not
sure I believe it the reason I suspect
that Trump really is Far and Away the
leader in the race right now is that
every single piece of evidence points to
that every single one it's not just one
poll or two polls it's not just the
Democrat polls it's not just the
Republican polls it's not just the it's
it's every poll says essentially the
same thing uh they they all have Trump
winning not by a little bit but by a ton
the Gap is huge uh the polls are not in
any way Dynamic polls have remained the
same basically from the
beginning uh in terms of I mean it's
still very early on in Iowa but in terms
of committed delegates I think Trump has
something like a two to1 lead on
committed delegates in Iowa uh it just
the the way that the race is structured
there were so many candidates none of
whom seem ready to drop out this is why
everyone knocked Dana Pino for her
question the other night about the game
show and Survivor who do you vote off
and it it was perhaps phrased in a silly
way but the the impetus for the question
is is a pretty serious one which is hey
if you all stay in the race nothing's
going to change and Trump is the nominee
so one of you has to get out multiple of
you have to get out if you even if any
of you even want to have a chance of
beating Donald Trump but none of them
have any incentive to get out right now
so because that's not changing I just
and because Trump is running effectively
as an incumbent which is something we
haven't seen in our lifetimes for a a
president seeking a non-consecutive
second term I'm inclined to believe that
it's not just all completely fake if it
if it's all if every single piece of
evidence is just completely fake then I
guess the conspiracy runs deeper even
than I had suspected next question hey
Michael I think it was around a year ago
this time that you had really first put
the thought in my mind that I needed to
look into Catholicism I grew up in a
really lukewarm Protestant
household but I it's taken me this long
and I think I'm ready to take the plunge
I believe the church is who she says she
is and I want to become a Catholic and
I'm just wondering where do I go from
here what are the steps I take any
advice would be great thanks Michael
great news I'm so pleased to hear that
that's wonderful uh it's probably not
too late to start our CIA which is the
right of Christian initiation for adults
so just contact your local Parish or you
know or maybe if you prefer going to
mass at a different Parish um you know
if maybe your local parish is a little
bit on the lib side and there's a more r
Mass somewhere else um just contact them
say I want to start rcia email the
parish secretary or the priest and
they'll get you started and then you
could be uh receive the sacraments by
Easter and that's great news really
really glad to hear it okay uh next
question hi Michael so there is one
thing that I think your audience can
wholeheartedly agree on and that is how
much we love hearing you talk about
sweet little Alisa you talk about her in
such a kind and loving way and I think
we would all love to hear the story of
how you propose
thanks again love the
show oh well this let's see the story of
how we proposed was we were down at
beach comr restaurant a great little
restaurant for breakfast in Orange
County California and I had uh purchased
the ring already at obviously and uh you
know I had known Alisa since we were 10
or 11 years old so what's amazing about
it is you still get extremely nervous
and so we go down for breakfast I said I
can't make it through breakfast if I
don't pop this question now so Alisa
goes she's like I'm Ma I'm going to go
use the restroom you know we just gotten
down there and I said not the most
romantic way to set it up I guess and I
said okay and I walked a little further
down the beach while we were waiting for
our table and Alisa only began to expect
it when she saw how far down the beach I
was cuz I didn't want to be around a
bunch of people and you know and then
just got down on one knee popped the
question and it was lovely it was really
great then we had breakfast then uh it
was just a great it was a marvelous
that's all that's all I have to say
about about that I don't know I didn't
do one of these things that modern
people do which is you know they hire a
band and like you know a mariachi band
and acrobats and a full film crew to
film it and post it on Tik Tok or
whatever just this lovely little private
moment on a beach before we had pancakes
and beet and coffee and Mimosas it was
great next question Michael you have to
understand how Democrats election
rigging Works in 20120 Trump pulled 10
million Independents away from Democrats
No One Believes that 20 million new
voters May in ballots for Democrats
because Trump made Mean Tweets a cursor
examination of those ballots found that
they were anonymously cast no court was
allowed to hear the evidence so
Democrats could deny there is proof they
know they can't get away with that again
so Pennsylvania is preemptively
registering everyone to vote so now they
can mail out ballots to their
headquarters and send them back with the
names of registered voters on them
whether those people cast a ballot or
not they'll also allow illegal aliens to
vote using the names of citizens who
never vote who's going to check their
IDs Democrats know they are a minority
now and must conduct extreme Ballot Box
stuffing to win they will make Shams of
all our future elections the fix is
already in to make 2024 a repeat of 2020
this is why Republicans must repair the
election system to a traditional State
one election day in person with
citizenship ID only no mail or
provisional ballots and only paper
ballots not computerized ballots this
would just be the beginning of repairing
our system that Democrats have
broken I agree is there any question I I
broadly agree I mean I I I guess the one
place I disagree is I think sometimes
the Democrats are a little subtler and
more sophisticated about how they stuff
The Ballot Box I I think that the way
that they harvest ballots the way that
they target places like nursing homes
the way that they you know stuff ballots
and lockers and the way that they
position the dropboxes and is a little
bit more clever than the blunt thing
that you've described uh but the the end
result is substantially the same it's
certainly the purpose of it I mean just
as the purpose of Democrats flooding the
country with illegal aliens is to give
them new voters down the line the
purpose of the widespread maons is is
for them to steal elections that's the
only reason 10 years ago Barack Obama
was admitting that widespread ment
ballots are open to fraud um but but
then they realized it would benefit them
during coid so now they're the big
supporters of it uh that's all true I
agree I mentioned that earlier in the
show actually that we're not focused
nearly enough on whoever the nominee is
Trump D santis VI I don't know Doug
berham uh how the Democrats aren't just
going to steal it again in precisely the
same way from
Alex hey Michael I've noticed as of late
the term uh the original sin being used
by leftists to say American slavery
obviously original sin is Adam and Eve
partaking of the forbidden fruit
why are they trying to Rebrand the
original sin my my initial thought is to
introduce the idea of baptism into the
worldly Church versus the Church of God
would love to hear your thoughts yeah
that's why I always hate that stupid
phrase when they say America's original
sin is
slavery it's not America's original sin
is original sin that would be the
original sin of Every Nation on Earth
and of all men tracing back to Adam
that's true um but yeah the the reason
they do that is
because they Center their political
Vision around man rather than around God
so the the original sin in the Garden of
Eden is a is a transgression of man
against God whereas the original sin of
slavery is a transgression they view it
I think as as a transgression of man
against man himself so it just becomes
totally
anthropocentric uh and it's it's very
shallow and silly obviously but it's
it's just a way for them to channel
their natural religious longings
uh toward an end that they can
acknowledge exists which is human beings
on this Earth and they don't allow their
natural religious longings to point them
up in their intellect and their desire
toward God who is the source and Summit
of those desires from Julie do you
believe in staying married forever if
you're not valued even if after 38 years
of marriage and three highly successful
kids all grown and on their own and a
very full life you know that there are
deep problems that will most likely
never change or with 20 plus years left
on Earth would you be better look for
happiness and compatibility elsewhere I
am opposed to divorce in all cases so uh
yes what you're describing here let me
find your exact wording what what you're
describing here
is deep there are deep problems and you
aren't valued and I don't want to
minimize that because that can be
extremely painful of course especially
painful when it's someone who's supposed
to love you the most who who behaves
that way with you that's true of a lot
of marriages a lot of marriages have
problems what I would recommend is
working on the marriage constantly every
single day and being being blunt and
honest about it I wouldn't just try to
paper over everything uh but I would I
would work on the marriage from the
premise that under no circumstances can
the marriage break because you have
three highly successful kids even for
your adult children the div divorce
would be a massive Scandal it's a not
just for little kids but for adult
children to to crack up the foundation
of their world to crack up the symbol of
the love of Christ in his church even if
you're didn't raise them in a
particularly religious way uh it's it
just it just completely cracks their
sense of the world U and it's a scandal
for society and it's a scandal that
leads other people down this path and
it's a reason that people don't get
married now because they say well 50% of
marriages end in divorce or whatever the
statistic is
it it's it's bad and do you really think
you're going to be so happy living alone
just CU your husband's sort of a jerk
sometimes okay now I'm going to be
better off of my own or you're going to
start dating at age 60 or something I
just think it's crazy I think the grass
is always greener and it's not to
minimize people in a in an unpleasant
marriage but the the only thing to do in
that the only reasonable thing to do it
seems to me is to work on the marriage I
don't think your husband wants to be Mis
miserable either you got to work on it
and and don't uh just
suspect that liberating yourself
emancipating yourself from your family
is going to make you happier I I
strongly doubt that it would okay
today's fake headline Friday the rest of
the show continues now you do not want
to miss it become a member and use code
NES kwes at checkout for two months free
on all annual
[Music]
plans